[Música]
bueno muchas gracias estoy feliz de
poder estar montado en este escenario
con tan grandes personas les cuento que
nací en los años 90 donde
las montañas de medellín todavía había
demasiada violencia estamos divididos
por muchas barreras invisibles y me
aterraba la forma en cómo nos cogían los
movimientos porque no podíamos
trasladarnos al otro barrio porque
bailas
bueno a través del tiempo quise formar
una compañía de arte una familia un
batallón un ejército y ahorita es un
ejército de paz es el ejército de paz
que quiero proponerle al mundo
recolectando
desplazando me por toda la ciudad
atrapando a todos estos artistas estos
niños que quieren y que creen en el arte
y que queremos seguir conquistando al
mundo a través de nuestras danzas ahora
a manrique la comuna 3 donde se hoy a
las 8 y media nos reunimos todos y todas
las noches estamos creando lo que son
coreografías performance
shows sus niños todas las noches están
soñando y viven enamorados de saber de
que se pueden montar en un escenario de
estos y que va a tener un público como
ustedes que los están aplaudiendo y que
les están diciendo
son valiosos son importantes
ahorita unión latina tiene 203 artistas
a partir de los 4 años hasta los 35
todos los estudiantes
son muy juiciosos y viven enamorados de
la vida eso es una posibilidad que se
fue formando a través de la pregunta que
yo siempre me hacía que era
para que vivimos para que existimos
y ahí está la familia esta es la familia
que inicio
unión latina
y ahí salieron un poco de laboratorios
comenzamos a investigar porque era la
violencia de todos los niños
y encontramos de que para poder ser
delincuente también se necesita ser muy
inteligente se necesita tener fuerza se
necesita
tener habilidad para agarrar un bolso
para salir corriendo y le a la policía
muchas cosas y nos encontramos que los
colegios también existen estos niños y a
estos niños los llaman y les dicen
pública dados necios canciones que todo
el tiempo están molestando y llegan a la
casa y en la casa también les dicen los
mismos que usted es muy necio resulta y
sucede que esos niños les dicen
hiperactivos niños que no se pueden
quedar quietos y son arrojados a la
calle donde está la otra universidad la
universidad de la delincuencia que es la
universidad que les dice ah listo se
tiene esas habilidades usted tiene esa
adrenalina y no le da miedo venga vea
que acá también puede formar una familia
enseñamos a robar le enseñamos a
delinquir a hacer miles de cosas unión
latina que hace
ahorita unión latina lo que hace es que
los formamos para que ellos crean en
ellos primero para que canalicen su
energía como canalizan la energía a
través del baile ustedes se imaginan
cómo podemos canalizar la energía a
través del baile
bueno les voy a comentar
resulta ser que para recibir clases para
poder bailar primero tenemos que dominar
la quietud entonces arrancamos en una
clase de baile y los ponemos van a
correr y todo el mundo a correr a correr
a correr a correr a correr a correr
esto
estos niños comienzan a sudar la
respiración se les agita son
en estos días se nos dé más yo uno
se nos del mayo uno y yo dios mío indicó
que vamos a hacer con este la
inspiración todo el mundo nervioso
porque porque la quietud la quietud para
poder llegar al baile primero tenemos
que tener quietud y esa quietud hay que
educarla si esa quietud no se educa y no
se le enseña al niño que es qué
esto también es natural es natural estar
moviéndonos
bueno quiero hacer un ejercicio con
todos ustedes qué rico que me acompañen
los veo como muy quietecitos vamos a
liberar un poco las manos y vamos a
hacer esto
para papá listo pa pa pa pa pero a manos
arriba 567 va pa pa pa pa mejor pa pa pa
pa ustedes
pep
[Aplausos]
muy bien el aplauso para ustedes
bueno les cuento
qué
hoy quería compartir con ustedes y
mostrarles y presentarles otro segundo
ejercicio ahora quiero que se me
coloquen de pie
a mí me gusta moverme
y listo vamos a tener las piernas semi
abiertas y a la medida de los hombros
resistencia se ve que bailar es tan
sencillo como caminar entonces vamos a
desplazar todo nuestro peso sobre la
pierna derecha o izquierda vamos a hacer
esto balanceamos nuestro hijo 3 todos
quiero verlos a todos hacia un lado al
otro vea qué hermosos de eventos iguales
de dívar acá
en ese momento estamos bailando ahora a
ese cambio de eje le vamos a pegar lo de
los latinos nosotros los latinos tenemos
vibración bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
bum bum muy bien una plaza para ustedes
[Aplausos]
bueno por medio de la danza
nos vemos nos hemos aprendido a conocer
a tener una gran familia y ahora en este
momento quiero presentarles el ejército
de la paz el ejército que quiere
enamorar conquistar al mundo por medio
del arte
todos queremos volar con ustedes
'alicia en tiempo de tango
[Aplausos]
[Música]